we are taking you to his show with
michael holly as we do every single day
here on nbc sports on peacock brother
from another's michael smith back here
on the program how are you doing michael
i'm good what's going on with y'all well
i don't know uh what's on top of your
mind today in the sports world what what
hits you uh anything uh
in particular that uh i'll i'll just uh
throw it up first i'll i'll pick it up
where i think we left our conversation
off
last week last week if our memory serves
okay uh we you and i
went back and forth about how the kyrie
situation would play out yep and whether
you you didn't think
if i recall you didn't think he would
ever
get the vaccine and this would come to a
head i was
optimistic that you know
peer pressure or stakes getting higher
would would uh have him
you know reverse course and and meet the
nets halfway they've already allowed him
to be a role player and he would come
around and and take the shot
um as he went through his process what
now
um you know there's talk that
you know if the nets
so chose or so choose they could pay a
fine yeah i saw that the daily news
right and i just i'm trying to process
what those optics would be like i'm good
with it and i'm as pro-vaxxed as they
come
i'm vaccinated boosted i'll get a second
booster shot if i can i think kyrie long
ago should have gotten the shot not just
in order to play but because this was
best for society in general in my
opinion but we don't have to unpack why
he didn't and it is what it is
but if the
ordinance the local ordinance is as such
where the fines are nominal
i would definitely play him and not
worry about the optics i don't think the
optics of paying a fine so that kyrie
can play
in new york is any worse than
20 000 unmasked people who may or may
not be boosted
transmitting a variant of a virus that
we know
does not discriminate even though the
effects are obviously different i'm not
trying to get a science class there but
we but does not discriminate in terms of
vaccinated or unvaccinated in terms of
who can catch it so the science has
continued to evolve
um there are plenty of nba players who
are not at the mercy of this ordinance i
don't think it would be a bad look for
the nets i know some people do maybe you
do i think it'll be a bad look for the
nets
if it came down to it to just stomach
the fine or or or swallow the fine
yeah and and again you're just kind of
michael you know um proving my point
which is this is this our this whole
story will be about not kyrie's choice
it's new york's choice
it's not kyrie's choice it's not about
the fact that he refuses to and uh my
ten-year-old yesterday
said to me michael
why isn't kyrie getting the shot
and my answer to him is and the children
shall lead us no he said he said dad why
won't kyrie take the shot and my answer
to him was
i don't
know right i don't know he is not
making it's just been all sorts of
complete
either avoidance of the subject refusal
to talk about it like what he really
knows like why why it's what he said dad
why won't he take the shot
and i said i do not no
and that again it's like why aren't
there articles about that
you know the new york daily news i saw
that article yesterday was it uh
stefan bondi or steve yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
okay
and and so he wrote and he he he wrote
in the paragraph a full paragraph about
how
you know it would be a bad look and
you know the mandate is the way it is in
new york city and he should take the
shot and all that
but
there shouldn't be a but like that's
what the mandate is there are there are
no hold on a second there are some
issues with the mandate i totally
understand like it's just like so
anybody unvaccinated from another team
can come in and play but he can't
anybody else who's in the building needs
to test out they can be there but he can
those are the rules
those are the rules and so so under
these rules but let's just stay there
let's just stay there okay those are the
rules yeah right and the fine for
breaking those rules
caps out at five thousand per day
correct which is ch which is chump
change for the brooklyn exactly so if
you want to make it really prohibitive
for josiah then make it 5 million
but since it's 5 000
i'm fine with that yeah but then so then
what about then what happens with the
rest of the businesses in new york that
are willing to do that sort of thing for
their employees like say fox news
right
i mean let's just jump into it here like
you know what i mean like what what if
other businesses in new york say you
know what we've got a few employees that
are very very important to us and we
would like to make some sort of a point
as well uh what's five grand that's it
honestly that's their that's their
prerogative like if you look if you're
looking for the brooklyn nets and kyrie
irving to set your agenda then you've
got other problems as far as i'm
concerned no different than the idea but
that's society at this point that's
society you're looking at kyrie irving
for whether or not you should get the
shot if you if you are unvaccinated and
you're holding out waiting to see if
kyrie gets it before you get it then
this i got nothing for you all i'm
saying is i think there is a but at this
point because it is what it is when it
comes to kyrie and kyrie is going to do
what kyrie is going to do but if i'm the
brooklyn nets
and kyrie irving makes me more of a
championship contender than i am i
seriously consider optics be damned i
seriously consider
whether or not it's worth it given the
fact that there are so many
inconsistencies and contradictions as it
relates to
this issue and rich remember you and i
are on team vaccinated we're on the same
team here but i'm just looking at it
strictly from a business perspective
when it comes to
the brooklyn nets
and i think there is a but if kyrie is
not going to take the shot the same
unvaccinated kyrie is playing other
places this is a specific issue to new
york or specific to
the bay area and the golden state
warriors or specific to toronto and the
raptors
other nba players around the country
have exemptions
so so the same guy has unvaccinated that
can't play in new york just went in
chicago and played last night
so it's not it's not a perfect system
all the way around and yes kyrie irving
should have gotten a shot in my opinion
in your opinion in a lot of people's
opinion
but he doesn't care about that that
opinion isn't gonna is gonna force him
to take the take the shot in the
meantime in between time if i'm the nets
i'm like and i'm sure they knew this
already i'm actually shocked they
haven't exploited already it'll happen
it'll happen i mean honestly
i mean yeah i mean like look this is the
way everything's gone and that's why i
said it's no longer going to be about
kyrie's decision
it's going to be about the mandate
that's what and mandates in general or
this one in pic that's what i said last
week and i think um
you know uh michael smith here uh on the
rich eisen show let's let's talk about
another inspiration by this time no no
no no let's talk you know i think some
people might be exasperated by the uh
the virus talk and uh you know coming
into their sports world so in that
respect uh if you are if you are um i
don't know let's start with this one um
if you're rob palinka you're thinking
what right now about the lakers what are
you thinking if you are the the
architect of this team or uh have uh had
lebron
you know assist in this process what are
you thinking
right now
i'm thinking thank god for lebron
i mean and where will we be without
lebron and hopefully more people talk
about lebron and hopefully more people
are like michael smith and are watching
the lakers
through the lens of a lebron
appreciation tour and not as a
championship contender even though
that's blasphemous in los angeles even
though that's all that matters in los
angeles is championship or bust
hopefully more people are just enjoying
the show that 37 year old lebron and
year 19 is putting on as he plays center
because if not for lebron
where would we be because there is
nowhere to go and there's nowhere to
turn and there's no realistic solution
because even in some
alternate
universe some multiverse that somebody
would actually trade for russell
westbrook and his cumbersome contract
the dude couldn't hit the broad side of
a barn right now and so he has
less than zero trade value there are no
realistic options to
you know truly
make over this team it's probably in all
likelihood fatally flawed and maybe we
could just sell ourselves and our fan
base on the hope
that not only will lebron keep up this
remarkable
practically unprecedented play for
somebody of his experience level uh but
anthony davis will come back and avoid
further fluke injury and having two of
the top 10
players in the nba
will make us a difficult out in the
playoffs and we can save face by
maybe making it to the second round if
we're lucky yeah i know that's not the
way the lakers normally operate though
right is uh you know come see come see
the show it's showtime and come see the
championship team and you know you have
to look at the west and say now that
lillard's gotten his uh app he's today
is gonna have surgery on his abdomen
he's out
for six to eight weeks last year the
blazers were a playoff team they're out
now
you know and uh the clippers last year
were that playoff team that purposely
lost right so they could avoid facing
the suns i don't think they're gonna
have any such benefit this year right
like that might be your playing game
like your state farm playing game might
be right there the home that's a part me
almost at staples crypto.com might be
the home of your state farm playing game
this year arena crypto.com arena my bad
sir
uh the crypt the crypt
like that's not that's not what you know
the lakers are supposed to be doing and
there is
you know uh some opportunity but then
you look at memphis right and you saw
like morant came in their building last
night and or a couple weeks a couple of
nights ago literally flew like like he
literally like he looked morant when he
blocked that ball the other night he
looked like some of those you know uh
acrobats that come in with trampolines
during you know time out of time
entertainment you know what i mean like
oh my god like
that's
that's the man
i got memphis on the same plane as uh as
phoenix and golden state right now what
i've seen what i saw without morant what
i've seen with morant who they've beaten
along the way
you know the whole adage especially in
the nba is you got to go through it to
get to it and you got to experience you
know a taste of the playoffs and play
off disappointment i mean look if you if
you forced me i'd still go with the
warriors based on that pedigree uh based
on their star power now they got clay
back yeah they do like by the way the
team that's got 30 dubs the dubs right
they just got one of the greatest
shooters in the history of the game back
you know and he looks pretty surprised
they're still the favorites but i'm
saying i put memphis in the contender
category this isn't just a upstart you
know spunky team i think i think they're
one of the three primary contenders in
the western conference you know if you
want to put utah in that category we're
going to put utah in a category two but
yeah no memphis is legit so
i mean the lakers are definitely gonna
probably be in play in territory but
having said all of that yes sir said all
of that the whole word salad right yes
it's like come play off time it's like
you're really trying to deal with lebron
james and maybe anthony davis and if
russell westbrook could just take care
of the ball and make a few more shots
there's enough about this team like i
can't stand roller coasters i cannot
stand them some people like roller
coasters i do not like roller coasters
but there's enough about this team to
make you keep getting on this ride
they're intriguing just enough
to to be relevant if not a factor early
in the western conference playoffs so
male 1
malik monk will keep their seven seed
hopes alive you know
while while melo gets healthy and then
the you know like the basketball version
of cocoon
does that make anthony davis steve
guttenberg in that whole thing i'm
trying to figure out brian dennehy
i don't know you know what i mean like
this is not this is not lakers
conversation it's just not you didn't
come see lebron and then you know um
the warriors have zoomed by them again i
mean that's the way it is right now
that's what i'm saying like there's no
move
there's no move coming up in the next
couple weeks there's nothing there
you know for that i mean like maybe they
trade tht i've you tell you tell me not
that i could see not that makes sense
for me
not not not from you know my trade my
personal trade machine no i don't see
anything there speaking of moves
i thought we i thought you'd be jumping
on the table about cam radish you're
next guy right
oh no uh i'm kind of fish ish
okay i mean i don't know what are we
getting we're we're we're putting duke
together in madison square garden
there's only one piece missing huh
there's only one piece
let's get it all together you know we
can have we could i don't know you
joking though you're joking how much
time have we spent over the years
talking about the one and two picks from
that draft zion and now ja
look at rj barrett
you know like this deputy was on the
come up youngest nick ever with
back-to-back 30-point games i told you
he's got to be the star of this team not
randall him
randall is you know an outstanding like
you know lightning in a bottle
type uh
making the most finally of his career
type stuff in new york city we
we new yorkers love that lunch pail type
story but barrett's got to be the star
of this team for them to start
being put in the context of what you're
putting memphis in you know what i'm
saying yeah that's what he's got to do
so all right so we get zion there what
are we gonna do should we get billis to
call the games i mean is that what we do
i mean walt's still there obviously
clyde's still the man i don't know what
we do how many more dookies can we get a
good move all right uh who's on your
show today
michael what do you got first
uh today is thursday so that means uh
the homie chris sims is falling through
and
tom habistro will come by to make us
smarter on all things nba okay very good
you and michael holly right after the
show on nbc sports on peacock once again
greatly appreciate the time in the chat
you'd be well sir
my pleasure tell your 10 year old son i
said hi he's much smarter than the rest
that's what he said honestly it's just
one of those things michael you know
where you he just throws you the
curveball he just looks at you and
you're like what's up and um you know
and he's like dad why won't kyrie take
the shot i'm like great question
you know
great question he's i you know what i
said to him i'm like son he's trying to
give voice to the voiceless you know did
you really say that i did not
i hope you think about it i hope you
picked up on the sarcasm i did not
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here